What is a data pipeline? That is one of the most fundamental components of being a good data
engineer and a good AI engineer nowadays. Let's talk a little bit about what a data pipeline is
and how there are three different types of data pipelines that we will be covering. We will cover
probably two of them in this bootcamp. So let's start off with what is a data pipeline. Data
pipeline is the ability to have flow of information that can then be translated into insight and
knowledge so that the business can make a better decision. That is at the highest level. That is
what a data pipeline is. So for example, maybe someone is like clicking buttons in your app and
that generates events. And then those events are pumped into a database and then enriched with
other data. And then we can know like there was 17 clicks in China or something like that, right?
That is going to be like the flow of information and data can come from all sorts of different
sources so there is like click stream data that might come from your application there's production
data that might be things like who are your users what posts have they created what are different
things like that that are in your production database you can also have third-party data like
maybe you have data from salesforce or maybe you have data from google analytics or maybe you have
data from hubspot or whatever there's a million other like third-party providers that you could
also synthesize data from.
And all of this data kind of flows in.
And then we want to be able to store all of this data
in a centralized location.
Back in the day, that was a relational database,
things like MySQL, Oracle, things like that.
And a lot of companies,
especially like if you're at a smaller scale,
that is still what you use.
You know, starting about 10 years ago,
things have shifted to being more
of a data lake architecture.
With the advent of cloud technologies,
we don't have to manage our own database anymore.
We don't have to do any of that.
and we can just store all of our data in the cloud in files.
The file system that we use in the cloud to store all of our data is a thing called S3 If you on Amazon and there like other ones for Azure and GCP that are very similar But we wanna consolidate all of our data into one space
so that like our Salesforce data, our HubSpot data,
our Qlik data and our production data is all in one place
so that we can then analyze it together
and come up with deeper insight.
That is the critical part of data engineering.
And this ability to get all of your data into one place also has relevance in AI because this is called context engineering.
With AI, we're going to be adding things like videos and text documents and audio files and like kind of that more like unstructured data.
But that can also be brought in to create a very rich and powerful context that your AI can make decisions off of or your analyst or your data scientist.
At the end of the day, data is only valuable because it changes decisions or it makes decisions better.
If you learn anything from this video at all, that is it.
Data is only valuable in as much as it impacts decisions.
And the more decisions that it impacts, the more valuable that it is.
Great. So how do data pipelines actually work, though?
Like, how do they actually run and how do they actually function?
So the very first technology that you really need to learn to really understand data pipelines is a thing called cron.
So cron is based on your computer's clock.
So every computer has a clock.
We need to go a little bit into details about how computers keep time.
Computers don't have a calendar because calendars are messy and for humans and based on the sun and computers don't need that.
Every moment in time is actually just a number.
It's called an epoch.
An epoch is the amount of seconds or milliseconds since January 1st, 1970.
That's and it's usually like I know it's like 16 billion, 17 billion or something like that.
Like every second is a different epoch, right?
That is how computers keep time, right?
Is they are aware of like how many seconds have passed since 1970.
If you want time before 1970 it just a negative number For a computer you can create a loop where every 80 seconds we run a job or we run a command
So like Cron is the ability to schedule things
based on the number of seconds between tasks, right?
For example, with Cron, you can have a job that runs every second.
Most data pipelines are not going to be running every second.
That's way too frequent.
Or they could run every minute or every hour or every day
or every month or every year.
they could run very, very frequently, or they can run very, very infrequently.
Cron is the technology that allows data pipelines to schedule.
And this causes the magic to happen.
This is the automation part, right?
Where like it's going to run every day, whether or not you click the run button.
It's going to run all the time in the background behind the scenes.
And that's why Cron is so powerful, right?
Cron is the fundamental technology behind all of the pipeline tools.
So there's so many pipeline tools out there like Airflow, Dagster, Prefect, and Mage, and Databricks Workflows,
and the list goes on and on and on and on about the number of actual pipeline technologies that you can work with.
Keeping in mind that all of these technologies at the end of the day, they use Cron to schedule.
You can think of it as Cron is the technology that allows your pipelines to run once a day or once an hour.
It's a very simple thing to think about. C-R-O-N.
Definitely check it out. Read more about it.
That's great. That's great. Because you want pipelines that can do that. And then like once
a day, we just process all of the data for that day. That works for most pipelines, actually. In
my career, about 90% of pipelines fit that pattern. They run once a day, and they process the data for
the day, and then you live happily ever after. But there are cases where you need other types
of pipelines. What about like in a case where once a day would be too late? Say someone stole
your credit card and they start racking up fraud, that pipeline needs to run sooner than once a day, right?
Because someone could like generate a lot of fraud and generate a lot of problems in a single day before they were detected.
Fraud detection is a good example of a pipeline that needs to run in real time What the difference between real time and pipelines that run on cron So real time pipelines are different in the fact that they don run on a schedule
They just run all of the time.
They're running all of the time.
And so how it's different is they are listening, right?
So they're listening for events and listening for data to come in.
You can imagine like a real time pipeline is sitting there with a basket and being like,
please events come in and I will process you.
That is what allows real-time pipelines to run all of the time.
Because they run all the time, they are generally more expensive,
harder to maintain, and just more complicated overall.
And they require a lot more technical skills.
So in this bootcamp, we will not be covering real-time pipelines
because they are more complicated.
And they only are like 5 or 10% of pipelines overall.
Remember I said that there was a third type of pipeline.
So the third type of pipeline is pipeline that runs on demand.
For example, when a user signs up,
Maybe we want to fetch a bunch of data about that user to build their profile.
So for them, it's like there might be a pipeline that gets triggered when they sign up.
So and that's going to be another type of pipeline that could potentially happen.
So that's called like an on-demand pipeline.
So those are going to be your three types of pipelines,
regularly scheduled pipelines, which is like 90% of them,
real-time pipelines, which is like 8% of them,
and then on-demand pipelines, which is like 1% or 2% of pipelines.
And then that's going to essentially cover every type of pipeline
that you can create as a data engineer.
To summarize here,
the fundamental technology here is Cron.
Cron is based on your computer's clock.
Your computer's clock is based on a number of seconds
since January 1st, 1970.
Every 80,000-ish seconds would be once a day.
And then that is gonna be how you segment
and schedule your pipelines.
Real-time pipelines are very useful for certain cases.
They're mostly useful for cases
where once a day is too slow
and you need to increase it better and increase it faster.
then on-demand pipelines have very specific use cases that can be very informational i
hope you found this video useful make sure to like comment and subscribe if you did